9 millions 1989 1995 9 millions 1989
1996 9 millions 989 1997 nettement se
voir mon serveur champagne s'il vous
plaît 98-99 99.5 attend que ça bloque
les 24 g passe ouais on va annuler le
champagne en fête dimanche à bonn voilà
je suis djabou du 15 août ont eu lieu
route au stade pareil norman tu vas où
bonjour je viens vous voir parce que
j'ai un projet phoenix n'ont pas si non
c'est sur cet avant son visage en fait à
non tu as vraiment sa tête posée sur ses
épaules
ok tu m'a cramé je travaille ici mais tu
voles youtube s'était pas très bien en
ce moment mais par contre ça reste en
premier écoutez j'ai un problème à ma
chaîne youtube est bloqué à neuf
millions 9 199 1999 abonnés il ya des
gens qui meurent de faim dans le monde
et monsieur à 10 millions d'abonnés sauf
que son compteur est bloqué et ça c'est
un problème one on est des problèmes
plus graves
mais bon c'est quand même un petit
problème quoi moi j'trouve ça écoute tu
vas aller au 14e étage au fond du
couloir à gauche il ya deux laboratoires
de celui qu'on appelle chez youtube
le spécialiste
ok merci des spécialistes sont des
spécialistes
d'accord est-ce qu'ils avaient tous
bonjour je viens parce qu'en fait j'ai
un problème au youtube heures désolé je
ne peux rien faire pour vous maintenant
laissez moi j'ai du travail
d'accord vous il paraît que vous êtes le
spécialiste mois le compteur de ma
chaîne youtube est bloqué je sais plus
quoi faire
à combien 9 millions 999 1999 vous avez
dit combien 9 millions 999 1999 combien
non je rigole 9 millions 999 1999 l'a
redit que le g pas écouté j'ai dit neuf
millions 9 cents quitter mon bref 10
millions kw à 10 millions - quoi oh mon
dieu c'est un bâtard et cible une
interférence dans l'algorithme de
youtube oui quand il ya trop d'honneur
pour le nombre d'abonnés le possesseur
du serveur prises nous avaient anticipé
la chose via quelques années que j'avais
mis au pot de clôture que tu avais
matrix 2 c'est pas pareil à l'accord tu
as aimé je trouve que ce scénario il est
pas mal a prévenu bronzés 3 web comment
on fait pour remédier à ce bug il ya une
solution aussi très risquée
cette façon de remédier à ce problème
c'est qu'on peut naître dans ta chaîne
youtube et qu'on a développés si on y
arrive
youpi mais si on échoue la chaîne
youtube sera à jamais supprimé
bah oui
aucun sommet
oui bonjour pour l'emploi j'avais une
question quel métier je peux faire c'est
tout d'un coup je j'arrête youtube a
aucun ok merci
j'accepte
c'est quoi ça ah ça c'est un rat on est
sûr de lui faire bouffer trois semaines
de tendance pour voir s'ils résistent ça
marche
norman es-tu prêt à pénétrer dans sa
chaîne youtube ouais alors suis point
voilà l'entrée du conduit ultra
dimensionnelle se situe ici
mais non je déconne regarde regarde j'ai
conçu cet appareil il ya quelques années
mais je n'ai encore jamais utilisée non
non c'est pas faim là j'ai envie de tout
sauf des figurines ont abouti c'est ça
l'entrée de la chaîne youtube
ok ok je posais paddock sco vêtements
jean-emmanuel ray show où on va rester
sur doc comment vas tu as vu là dessus
et attention les yeux
pour l'instant c'est pas au vent
norman
normal on est arrivé là pardon
et oh il ya quelqu'un quelqu'un
quelqu'un voudrait que je perds ce
normal bienvenu dans ta chaîne youtube
c'est vraiment mieux que celle de
squeeze je cherchais wahlberg
et on peut entrer comme ça dans you
don't par exemple ça m'intéresse
frikha j'encourage tous mes potos
vendeurs et vendeuses parce qu'ils font
un métier pas évident c'est bizarre je
ne trouve pas de trace de bugs de
l'appétit g
attends tu avais passé de bananes en
arrivant maintenant j'ai pris sur mon
bureau parce pondre leurs oeufs dans une
lido pas quoi mais tu n'aurais jamais pu
faire ça désormais collection va rester
gravé à tout jamais dans la vidéo les
vendeurs à très précisément 4 minutes et
11 secondes ta g d'amandes c'est grave
qui tu viens de vous dire que l'espace
quand tu es en train de faire disjoncter
tâche elle est peut-être même tu risques
de supprimer je suis comme ça veut dire
plus de vidéos de dégustation en couple
plus de fringues plus de story times non
c'est plutôt bien en fait ouais je vous
entends des cas c'est la merde pour là
il se réfugier dans une autre vidéo là
bas sa vidéo faire les courses
allons-y
ok ici au moins on est en sécurité
sunrise cherche le rayon gluten free to
play face en gluten je passe si vous
parlez anglais
donc il ya moi qui nous parle là il ya
le personnage de ma vidéo les bilingues
et il nous parle de comprendre la
référence à mélanger le tout et vidéo
est là là ce sont toutes des personnages
qui se retrouvent bloqués dans l'univers
de ta vidéo forêt course
est-ce que tu ressors mon apple facetime
ouais ok excuse moi j'en appelle avec
mon deuxième téléphone apple un match au
couteau que jacquotte déchets qu'on ne
le cachons date de ch'nord c'est pas des
bruits de fraudeurs c'est du ch'timi
désolé de dire si c'était un apple store
1 c'est plutôt un mix entre une épicerie
bio un concept store un foutraque
friperie éphémère en boucherie des
gannes au supermarché c'est clairement
excellente dans le concept par le l'air
écoutez moi bien ça peut sembler bizarre
mais voilà je suis votre créateur vous
êtes mes personnages et je suis venu ici
pour me sauver d'accord autant se
comprend au peuple moi je suis pas un
personnage pour ta conti gipa personnage
est tjs pas les couilles ce dimanche toi
c'est quoi ce bordel dit syrie analyse
moi la situation je te plaît pour qui tu
te prends c'est plutôt toi l'intrus
pour l'heure ma gauche
hot mois que j'étais ici ah merde mais
si tu fais la ferme est demandé à tout
donner pour moi j'étais d'accord ok
on va leur jeter des tomates si on va
les déstabiliser un support c'est
clairement le bordel un problème j'en
vois les zones de lotto 6 pour moudre et
norman font croire à un jeu comme j'aime
ce soir
foutu merlin
tout homogène
g
allaire se dégage
non cette fois normal je crois que c'est
la fin et ouais c'est la femme en petits
potes et va goûter à mon calibre et je
parle pas de celui que j'ai entre les
deux fils ok vous êtes des inventions
d'accord je vous ai inventé rick tocchet
une parodie hyundai quoi je dors loi tu
vas dire j'adore le concept où elle
attend le bec a clairement devant c'est
ce que te le dire clairement dans petit
opus c'est excellent oui je vous
inventez bon ça c'est pas un supermarché
seulement 1 des corses et des pixels
regarder les bluffs d'un contrôleur
regardez ces gens qui rient
ah non pas tous
al battar si vous me supprimer je ne
sera pas des bugs et compteur restera
bloqué à neuf millions 9 199 1999
tant pis les chais sont bloqués ça m'est
égal
sauf que ce que vous oubliez c'est que
derrière ces chiffres il ya vu
très encore plus de monde qu'au burning
man quoi et eux moi j'ai pas envie de
décevoir
moi je le crois je pose mon gun à la
manière de kool shen bien dit ça bravo
normal bien muscu comme discours mais ça
a fonctionné
par contre maintenant on est toujours
dans la merde je ne sais pas comment
rentrer au labour il faut quelque chose
qui nous unit tous quelque chose qui
nous unit tous je crois savoir
infi liste oui bien sûr c'est le fond
qui vous unit
j'aime
boorman
norman ça fait quinze minutes qu'on est
arrivé à la fois son bonheur ah oui ça
c'est le problème de ceux grille-pain ce
qui fait aussi la grippe a
tant mieux comme ça moi je ressemble à
mes grands-pères minières dans les mines
de charbon du nord de la france
on les appelait les guenons nous en bas
les couilles entouré car leur réussit et
ça c'est grâce à l'amour des internautes
et à toi merci doc derrien marty partie
ah oui non pardon norman norman mes
collègues de youtube ont quelque chose
d'être belle
c'est quoi j'ai pas le prendre vous
abonner me suffisent
en fait je peux reconnaître wahou 10
millions d'abonnés ultime merci à toutes
et à 12
me donne envie d'aller encore plus loin
sur ma chaîne youtube goto 600 milliards
norman excuse moi mais j'ai l'impression
que tu t'enflammes un tout petit peu mal
d'avoir des rêves